okay we rolling are we rolling we doing
this
are we doing that but sangeeta i they
were going yes this is the interview
I've been looking forward to all my life
really to meet you oh that's so nice
thank you it's because I love cookies
too you do I do what what you favorite
kind like that me favorite kind me too
maybe I have a surprise for you later on
what I do what is it it's okay how long
with interview going on for well for a
bit okay okay get to it 50 years yeah
it's your anniversary of Sesame Street
did you think you would last this long
50 years last 50 years you look good
thank you it mean that drill for a color
yeah you have a great regime going on
there what does it mean 50 years you've
been celebrating with such a great team
and helping so many kids out there yeah
I don't want the cookies a lot of
cookies yeah well you know 50 years on
Sesame Street that's where me met all my
friends yeah need learn a lot lots of
different kinds of people monsters and
animals and humans and uh it made me the
monster whom am I talking about humans
you've had a lot of celebrities on you
yeah any any favorites what me no can
pick favorite but we hope but John
Legend just came on Sesame I know John
Legend song
oh boy what me fit there's so many I
know there's so many I mean dough can
pick one I know he sell me love his
voice yeah and he just sat down the
piano and just he just played piano well
yeah I knew it just learned the song in
like three seconds yeah and it was
terrific did you meet Michelle Obama -
oh yeah how was that lover yeah well you
know G all about healthy eating mm-hmm
so its first she was like you are Cookie
Monster me not so sure about you but we
said you know what may not only eat
cookie
yeah meal of all kind food like what
else oh me like the judge the ball like
fruit like bicycle and you know Meads
everything no Sesame Street's in New
York City they opened up a street there
were you there celebrating as well is
there wasn't that amazing don't predict
yeah yes oh you know when someone says
can you tell me how to get how to get to
Sesame Street
me just point the street sign right
there yeah sing that again sorry Dave
sweeping up clouds no way yeah sorry
you know honey I'm god they're just you
know yeah yeah no but I got it I got it
okay and on Twitter they said they had
this whole thing where they want to know
about who you would want to be stranded
on a deserted island Big Bird wasn't on
the list really no do you think that's
because he would fly away yeah oh you
know big birdy I know can fly yeah who
would you want to be stranded on the
deserted island with Oh me mummy me love
me mummy Oh me think that'd be fun that
would be fun to be nice now are you
ready for your special Baker or Baker
with stuff all week that he came
prepared to make cookies oh are you
ready for a surprise I
so we baked something for you are you
ready
it smell okay you smell it take
somewhere around here do you dip it in
milk you like it in Omega go to yummy
love this dip in milk yeah that a good
cook you know what that cookie not make
any crumbs no not go down easy it's so
good Wow we should share this with
everybody shouldn't we yeah you know
what that one thing we learned on Sesame
Street good thing to share cookies
that's a good idea
let's do hate the cruel camera
you are the cookie where the sound guy
sound guy I think it's just you and me
in this room you're a person I know
Alicia you want a cookie they won't want
a cookie guy who brought prop into the
interview you want a cookie
no takers okay we offered just you and
me so you know what my favorite song is
Wow c is for cookie yeah that's a good
that was good enough for me is that your
favorite song to you yeah like that one
should we sing it together okay here we
go
c is for cookie that's good enough for
me
c is for cookie that's good enough for
me
c is for cookie that's good enough for
me
Oh cookie cookie cookie starts with C
50th thank you another 50 years yeah me
old soul
I think so yeah